la désinformation en Afrique et elle est
pas très différente de ce qui se passe
ailleurs dans le monde je pense que
on fait face au même problématique
[Musique]
nous faisons face à des problèmes qui
sont inhérents à nos réalités sur le
continent conflit au Sahel
pandémie etc etc mais les enjeux restent
les mêmes parce que sur le panel
tout à l'heure on s'est rendu compte
qu'on fait quand même face au même
problématique qu'on soit à Dakar à Paris
à Beyrouth ou à New York
les actions mises en place pour lutter
contre la désinformations en Afrique
sont son diverses déjà c'est la pratique
de la vérification des faits du Fat
check-in nous essayons nous en tant
qu'Africain tchèque de promouvoir au
maximum la pratique je suis à checker
sur le continent plusieurs organisations
de fatigue ont vu le jour en Afrique
grâce au soutien à l'encadrement
technique de Africa tchèque le deuxième
aspect c'est l'éducation médias qui
reste encore je dirais assez
balbutiements il faut multiplier les
initiatives dans ce sens parce que voilà
c'est un pour moi un élément important
qui viendra s'ajouter au travail que
font les fatigue parce que l'éducation
médias permet de mieux préparer le
public déjà à être réceptif quant au
travail que font les journalistes et
aussi d'être averti du danger de la
désinformation et parfois même d'être
outillés pour pouvoir détecter ou
identifier une information tropeuse ou
erronée et puis enfin je pense que il
faut
mettre des cadres légaux qui notamment
peuvent encourager
l'accès à l'information qui reste aussi
un très gros problème parce qu'on
absence d'accès à l'information à des
informations s'installe
il faut vraiment
mettre l'accent sur ces éléments là
c'est à dire que
permettent aux journalistes
le travail dans des environnements qui
qui leur facilite la tâche et c'est pas
pour c'est pas pour chacun mais c'est
parfois peut-être certaines sujets plus
facile de faire une vérification en
France
que dans un pays en Afrique où l'accès à
l'information n'est pas toujours
garantie notamment auprès des autorités
publiques donc ça une chose sur laquelle
j'aimerais insister et donc aussi sur
l'éducation aux médias qui pour moi est
vraiment vraiment essentiel pour
construire un public critique et un
public qui comprend les enjeux auxquels
on fait face